hello and welcome sorry to this video
playing e m i am
buki 23 i went for e4
just for variety's sake
and got this
really
delayed
allo pin it's a pretty ambitious gambit
if you ask me with a6 being played
well it looks like it shouldn't work at
all actually
if i get d4 in what's the compensation
okay so could take with the queen even
but knight takes looks perfectly right
yeah i'm attacking
the knight or the bishop on e6 and
black cannot um yeah allow me to take
that
and the damage damages pawn structure
terminally
so move it again with where
it's a pretty odd opening play
yeah i'm curious so
allows me to take after all okay the
thing is
my king position would be
pretty shaky um that is definitely the
case
yeah okay that is not
that is not a 100 clear
situation because of my non-developed
of of the of the pieces 96 quindy one
kindy one
fe-6 and he has knight d4 and knight b4
coming
that is indeed not clear
maybe i have to take on c6
and this way prevent him from jumping
into d4 yeah this is probably a better
way to do it
yeah yeah i should have i should have
found this
found as a strong word i should have
made this decision a lot quicker
now with king e2 bishop e3 and so on i
have a
reasonably quick and um
harmonious development i feel
unless he has a very quick way to
disturb me like
maybe knight to g4 knight to e5 things
like that
that is not not not so clear
yep that is indeed a problem
95 and rook to the 8 things like that
are on the cards
i don't want to give back material
king e2 there's even castle and queen
side
should be three or two not so clear
remarkable
rook d8 he even has this threat of
taking on d3
or long castling let's say
i'm not even sure what i'm playing after
that okay
ship c5
not happy about this move but
my time situation is not great
interesting interesting i must have made
some
some mistake there because the opening
play
the black is certainly not great
i think here at least i'm not in trouble
i can
probably just play a rook to e1 king to
c2 and
return the e3 pawn for an equal position
i should i think it should be equal he
has the bishop pair but
his pawn structure on the queen side is
not really all that fantastic
okay it seems he wants to provoke this
weakness
which yeah seems seems like a reasonable
idea
i have to go away from the default
anyway so
b3 to make this bishop
more mobile
here and then bishop e2 f3
and kind of trying to sort my position
it's um
very difficult to ever convert such a
pawn
the knight um should probably
come to d3 that would be a
a good square
i think he will probably try to play f5
this is why i'm
playing g4 i know it it makes my bishop
look even
more ridiculous but
it's not such a bad strategy
so this is coming to d3 now
yeah as i said i'm i don't think i'm
better here or anything i just have to
try to make the best of my chances
okay go a4 i guess
not sure how i'm making any headway here
king e3
a3b4 maybe he's got the check here on g1
a3b4c5 yeah that would be
some progress
yeah i probably have to
have to do this
shut it down and now
try to get the bishop to d3
and things like that
knight f3
okay if i take it then h6
i have no time it's a little bit of a
bit risky
but okay
not sure if i'm still not sure that
i can win here okay
this is helping
yeah i don't think i should should win
this ending
but um it was a tricky it was tricky
with no time on the clock
and i don't really think that this is a
playable gambit that
would be really odd there is this idea
um without a6 and knight f3
um played and this is
already a little bit dodgy like if we
compare this
there is this
and this is supposed to be incorrect as
far as i know
and now we had this with this
knight f3 a6 inserted so i'm
kind of skeptical about it but
interestingly um
the stockfish engine on a i mean
admittedly low
depth kind of endorses the scam bit
maybe i mean d4 is definitely possible
maybe this is better i don't know i i'm
a little bit surprised i wouldn't think
that
this could be enough
but probably
it's it's interesting so i mean if if
anything
is a try at a refutation it is d4
because if i play something else like
this knight c6 he will be on that square
and if i don't manage to play d4 that
will be enough
i think for black black has a very
simple
development plan like this bishop out
castling either side and then just
centralize and say
okay the d pawn is worthless black has
all the
activity so this is clear that this is
fine
the thing is what i thought
when i saw this i get in d4 and i felt
that this should not be enough but it's
possible that the development is really
enough
knight c6 played in the game which
already wasn't clear
honestly i i couldn't believe it but
it seems to be the case knight c6 yeah
what he played bishop c5
also seems to be interesting yeah based
on
this trick i guess yeah
it's not not like losing immediately but
it's um it's a it's a thing
i can probably play this knight g4
knight c3
yeah it's definitely playable for black
i mean no doubt
okay he played knight c6 and now
i originally thought i would take here
but
this looked really dangerous like from a
strategic point of view i'd love to take
on e6
but my my fear was that he's so quick
now he's got
rook d8 or castle in queenside with a
check
knight d4 coming i mean i have no
development like
no development so
yeah this this felt like the most yeah
like like what should be tried i thought
like he would do this
king c1 and then knight g4 that that
that was my
my thought and i felt that this is true
i can go to b6
ah that is a very important resource ah
i didn't see that
because what i thought is i have no i
have nothing here to prevent him from
taking and playing this and then it's
definitely fine i mean something like
this is what i'm
felt should happen and i mean this is
fine for black he gets the pawn back and
is probably um yeah the engine says
equal but this is
much easier for black to play so that
was my fear but maybe
the point that i have this move
sometimes was
uh was something that that that i
definitely missed and it changes the
evaluation quite considerably i guess
so this is probably good for white after
all but
very difficult i mean not so difficult i
didn't see it
um i took on c6 ultimately
thinking that here at least i don't have
to worry about
a knight coming to d4 but black's
development is really good and
i think that here i thought
long castles is strong yes or rook g8
he didn't do that he played bishop c5 i
was thinking one of those
and now there's this this threat and
that is really annoying
really annoying the the engine
finds knight c3 and simply accept this
which is maybe a thing yeah something
like where do i go
like here here and then this to get it
back
which is the like i lose c4 right
that's actually pretty awful for white
yeah i don't know
i don't know
i don't know i thought bishop e3
but after knight e5 i didn't quite know
what i would do oh we can take and give
the check and kill me already
wow wow
why is that just want to see the precise
line
this this and rookie area yeah yeah he
have no development
yeah it was that was really awful yeah
if he castles queen side or rook d8
after bishop c5 i think that still looks
uncomfortable but
um at least i'm not losing
yeah castle and queen side is stronger
i has a fairly yeah rookie 8 maybe i
don't know black has a really
really good compensation for the pawn
look d7 just doubling
yeah i have to play this and hope that
he takes it
this is even better right because i have
a hard time to move the bishop for rook
d2
wow okay so i don't want to analyze this
for
for an hour but it was interesting
so i think that in that ending
um when we got to the pure
minor piece ending this is a reasonably
easy draw for black if he just
sits and doesn't do anything because
my bishop is just bad and
something what he did like a5 put put
pawns on dark squares something like
that
is probably um enough i would play c5
with black actually
maybe he wanted to um win yeah that's
possible
but if you if you like put this put this
here
on c5 and the bishop over to d4 then we
basically
we basically go home yeah
this is also still a draw i think
i went i went um here
if i take and he can easily play this i
mean i never win this position
impossible can just shuffle bishop is
just
terrible yeah and here um b5
the engine um it gives me a huge
advantage but
i honestly doubt that because if he
plays um
let's say bishop e5 and just stays
just doesn't do anything i don't see how
i'm making a headway
here yeah that is tough to say
it's a funny funny mis-evaluation of a
stockfish yeah this
this is 1.2 which which is an immediate
draw
yeah this is an immediate draw black is
just
play pre-moving bishop f7 e6 bishop f7
e6 10
till the end of days yeah um
it's just a complete fortress so this is
a case where the engines here are still
crap just just completely drawn
and i think the whole position is drawn
i mean i'm never taking here of course
if i want to try something but it's just
dead
something like this you play i can
actually take on
i can prepare it i just want to show
like here if i
try for this yeah then you can again
probably hack it
but that could be actually a problem
yeah black shouldn't take on b2 here
yeah but anyway even if i get here what
is this what is my threat like
like this i go b6 that cannot win
and something like this will always be
taken knight on d5
i think this is a draw he um i think he
was too ambitious here with h5 simply
and i mean i can take if he takes this i
have h6 and this is running
running all the way
and um here i'm all of a sudden winning
i think he was probably just uh being
too
uh too ambitious there which can happen
of course if you have no time you're
kind of yeah want to go forward and this
was not warranted here
okay guys thanks for watching